you
so when you're considering non-ordinary
or altered states one of the first
questions is you know what do they feel
like what's actually going on in those
places and spaces and one of the
challenges in coming up with a good and
consistent answer not just for a
specific state like meditation or a flow
state or a psychedelic state is how do
they or what qualities do they all share
because each of those communities of
practice over decades centuries and even
millennia have accumulated their own
storytelling or content about what the
state they access are or what they mean
and where you're supposed to go through
them so for instance if you're a
buddhist meditator you will be
instructed in all sorts of stages and
levels and progressions of non-ordinary
states of consciousness ranging from
waking state all the way to white light
boy to Buddha consciousness etc if I am
a peasant farmer in India and I have a
non-ordinary state experience I might
experience Ganesh right the elephant God
in a rice paddy if I am a peasant in
Mexico I might experience the virgin of
guadalupe hidalgo right if I'm a coder
in Silicon Valley I might experience the
matrix and code mode or use this is
one-zero streaming all night as I bang
away on my keyboard and the reality is
is that underneath those experiences of
far more alike than the wrapping-paper
the narrative wrapping paper what people
see based on culture custom biography
and what we what we attempted to do is
create a functional framework that lets
us talk about these things as apples to
apples and really see the similarities
and and what we realize is that because
of the neurobiology there are four
qualities that tend to arise pretty
consistently regardless of which door
you go through to get into these Nordic
Naumann Airy States and they are
selflessness timelessness
effortlessness and richness or stir for
short and selflessness tends to happen
because the areas of our brain
specifically the prefrontal cortex but
including additional networks that
connect often turn off or completely
light up either way
they knock out our everyday waking sense
of self-consciousness and self-awareness
so we end up momentarily lost our inner
voice lost our inner critic luster
Jiminy Cricket right and we are in a
state of not thinking about our thinking
timelessness happens for a similar
reason and as basically different parts
of our brain light up and turn off our
ability to calculate time gets knocked
out because it is a is a comprehensive
measurement it's not doesn't just occur
in one single location in our brain so
when we start knocking out parts of the
network's
we lose our chronometer and all of the
neuro chemistry breaks focusing
attention learning drives our attention
we drop out of day dreaming about the
past or the future and we get absolutely
sucked into the immediate present moment
so a feeling of timelessness comes with
it the effortlessness is just it's no
longer about what I'm trying to do it's
not about exerting grit or willpower
which has been you know a lot of people
have been talking about and writing
about these days and it's literally in
the sort of almost in the biblical sense
sort of not my will but thy will I feel
myself swept along and it can be I'm
just self propelled and it feels awesome
or it's terrifying but I don't have a
choice but either way it's not me
plotting one foot in front of the other
to get to a goal I've decided so that's
the effortlessness
and then the final village which is the
richness and that's arguably the whole
shooting match because when I knock out
my self-consciousness
I don't have a voice inside my head
second-guessing filtering when I'm not
in the past or the future I'm just in
the deep present when I am effortlessly
being propelled the next thing that
consistently seems to happen is we have
access to far more information than we
do in our regular waking state and that
is when we go from conscious processing
which is very limited and narrow to
unconscious processing which is faster
and vaster and dr. David Newman who's at
Stanford who's a friend and a colleague
and a board member of ours at the flow
Genome Project well you know constantly
makes that case that that really it's as
if our conscious mind is sort of
like the headlines of tomorrow's
newspaper reporting a home for the
reality of today and when we get into
non-ordinary states because of the all
the shifts in brain function and and
hormones and neural ectric city we have
access to more of that information in
real time and and the results often feel
super natural people in the past
historically have assigned this to the
gods to the muses to fate
two-possession to Angel you name it
right we pretty much exhausted a gamut
of all the ways we could say this is
just too much this is too cool it's too
inspired is - its - informed to possibly
be me so we've assigned it's
supernatural
origins but in reality we now know it
might just be super - natural it's just
us in an optimum ativ state it's it's
it's big data for our minds
[Music]
you